Now I'll move forward with
the JSON example, and
I think you're really
going to like this.
Now the code is almost identical, but
what happened to all of our functions
that help us visualize the maze?
I'm going to show you something
that's pretty cool with playgrounds.
So we're looking at
the maze JSON example.
If we drop this down,
let's look in this Sources.swift file.
Now here it is.
In this file, we have all
the functions that we defined earlier
that help us visualize the maze.
So everything defined in the Sources
folder, so this Sources.swift file, and
any additional files we may have,
they can be accessed by
our Maze JSON Example.
So let's go back to that file here.
And you'll notice just some small
differences between this example with
JSON and
the PList examples that we've seen.
But the difference is small.
First, we need to create a URL that
points to the JSON file instead of
the PList file.
Then we load the JSON data
into an NSData object.
Now this is a little bit
different than we saw earlier.
At this point our data is raw,
it's not organized into an array, or
a dictionary, we're going to
have to do that ourselves.
These next few lines of
code use the do keyword,
which we'll discuss later
when we get to errors.
Do will allow us to run some code that
could potentially cause an error, but
in our case, it'll work,
as long as we specify the file name
here and the extension correctly.
Inside the do block,
we run some code that'll convert the raw
JSON data into a usable dictionary.
Then from there, we call our
visualizeMaze function again and
it visualizes the maze as this string.
So now we've created the same maze
from two different data formats,
with a Plist and with JSON.
That's awesome, and for
a little fun I encourage you to try
messing with the truth values
in either of the files, and
see how it affects this maze
that's ultimately generated.